bom dia a todos é um prazer imenso
retornar a porto alegre prazer imenso de
uma platéia bonito desse jeito é tentar
falar um pouquinho sobre algumas coisas
que inspiram vocês mas primeiro vou
começar fazendo algumas provocações vão
ver que o que se passa
depois disso obviamente que como como um
filho da puc de são paulo e som
eu não posso começar uma palestra
falando de educação sem citar uma pessoa
que é um marco
chamado paulo freire numa das minhas
citações favoritas que é ninguém educa
ninguém ninguém educa si mesmo
os homens se educam o entre se uns aos
outros mediatizados pelo mundo
alguém já ouviu essa frase sim levanta a
mão quem já viu bom legal muito boa né
agora vou brincar brincar um pouco com
vocês e vou pedir pra todo mundo fechou
os olhos eu posso fazer isso porque
afinal não é depois do meio dia
não fechem os olhos e tenta imaginar
três situações tenta pensar numa sala de
aula do século 18 com poucas crianças
afinal no século 18 educação era
privilégio de poucos
nenhum contato com o mundo externo a não
ser aquela pessoa que hoje a gente chama
de professor mas talvez naquela época se
chamava semestre porque a pessoa que
conhecia o mundo imagina o que significa
essa frase de paulo freire nesse
contexto de educação mediatizada pelo
mundo onde o mundo era simplesmente o
professor que tinha todo o conhecimento
e efetivamente estava em frente deles
contando o imagine uma sala do século 19
como as fotos do meio onde existia um
outro contato com o exterior que era
através dos livros mas ainda assim a
maior referência do professor o
eventualmente depois da democratização
da educação no século 20 onde tínhamos
salas lotadas e efetivamente ainda assim
pouco contato com o exterior
imagina essas três situações imagine
aquela frase de paulo freire onde ele
fala que nós somos
carlos uns pelos outros mediatizados por
esse mundo
a gente pode imaginar que a educação
então era um pouquinho restrita agora
abram os olhos e dêem uma olhada nesta
foto
estes são os principais bebo nunes de
internet no mundo
se você colocar o mapa do mundo ali
atrás para ver estados unidos europa
américa do sul áfrica e aquele indo pro
lado do oriente
imagine o que significa uma educação
mediatizada pelo mundo aonde o mundo
está conectado onde o mundo é
efetivamente um lugar onde todo mundo
tenha potencial a possibilidade de se
comunicar com todo mundo
imagine um mundo onde você consegue
assistir uma defesa de mestrado
mesmo não estando presencialmente no
local através do second life
imagine um mundo nessa são fotos rolar
aquela moça chique de vestido dourado de
prince vestido rosa de princesa é a a
moça que está defendendo o mestrado
achei que isso é muito bom hoje em dia
os jovens gostam muito de passar o seu
tempo seu tempo à frente à internet
frente do computador frente um celular
foi diferente um tablet e esse é um bom
exemplo de muitos que de sites que
jovens gostam de falar os jovens e
parecendo que não sou do meio né eu não
sou mesmo
estou chegando a 200 já o que vocês
imaginam que a parte que esses jovens
mais gostam nesse tipo de site com a
parte que lhes mais efetivamente
utilizam-nas a 1
o vídeo em si as propagandas nas
laterais
a parte que lhes mais utilizam em gostam
é uma parte que chama compartilhe a
maior parte hoje em dia dos acessos aos
grandes portais de notícias
através de redes sociais porque alguém
compartilhou a notícia com seus amigos
da sua rede
eu nem conhecia todos esses vocês
conhecem eu não conhecia metade nem
sabia que existiam tantas formas de
compartilhar e aí obviamente nesse meio
todo
quando a gente está dentro da sala de
aula quando o professor na sala de aula
ele fica com aquela cara de aloprado
estou vendo que pouca gente riu então
deixa eu colocar uma versão mais nova da
foto
agora sim temos mais jovens a kibon e aí
vem a grande questão da nossa sala de
aula atual e do que ela poderia sonhar
em ser hoje a gente tem um mundo que nos
fala que nós temos que ser cada vez mais
protagonistas mais autores
mas a nossa sala de aula ainda encara o
nosso estudante como um ouvinte passivo
onde voltando novamente a paulo freire
nós temos uma educação bancária
compartimentada primeiro matemática
depois ciências depois história não pode
ter história com matemática onde já se
viu
e tem um segundo problema também porque
no final das contas no mundo onde esses
jovens convivem cada vez com mais
tecnologia a nossa escola ainda está
pensando em discutir se efetivamente
vamos ter um laboratório de informática
um computador por aluno
esses jovens já são múltiplos devices em
duas mãozinhas pequenas
eles já têm um tablet um celular um
notebook e um desktop se duvidar eles
acesso à internet até pela televisão
a sessão da tarde não está legal não tem
problema eu vou ficar eu vou pro canal
do youtube com vários exemplos nós vamos
ver aqui hoje é por demanda
e aí o que acontece com isso tudo
a escola se afasta dos seus alunos e
para o nosso professor
fica uma coisa ainda mais complicada
porque às vezes por conta de ficar
naquele lugar próprio não querer sair da
sua zona de conforto
ele também se afasta do seu aluno ea
gente escuta casos de alunos não são
interessados mas lógico no mundo lá fora
eu sei que se eu quiser aprender alguma
coisa nesse exato momento eu
simplesmente entro na internet procuro
professor professor tem uma dúvida
calma meu filho porque você quer que eu
responda isso pra você agora é só do
terceiro bimestre
pra quê a pressa em aprender e aí esse
afastamento eles motivos alunos mas
efetivamente eles valorizam os
professores se uma palestra e se diz
muito legal onde mostrava provar por a
mais b que hoje em dia o nosso professor
é simplesmente um esquentador de marmita
e microondas porque ele simplesmente
pega um conteúdo totalmente pronto e de
burla sobre os seus alunos
a gente precisa de criadores
a gente precisa de pessoas inovadoras a
gente precisa de pessoas que
efetivamente trabalham com isso é bom
pra frente se movam criem compartilhem
colabore
esse professor simplesmente ficar
esquentando a sua marmita ele no final
do dia está sendo desvalorizada porque
ele pode muito mais
ele sabe muito maiores mas ele tem que
seguir o protocolo e aí obviamente a
nossa juventude hoje não se reconhece
nações na sua escola e aí
por conta dessas questões todas que a
gente consegue observar por aí a gente
chega a algumas conclusões de como fazer
para mudar e é isso que eu gostaria de
compartilhar com vocês nesses seis
minutos que me restam primeiro é óbvio
não existe mais como você deixará a sala
de aula desconectada dos avanços
tecnológicos que estão fora dela
é uma questão de agora é uma questão de
ontem os nossos alunos já convivem com
isso todo dia tenho certeza que todo
mundo aqui já ouviu alguém contar uma
história de uma criança de três ou
quatro anos que chegou na frente da
televisão e fez assim nós já não falou
isso não aconteceu na casa de vocês já
ouviram isso não é óbvio
nós estamos num mundo touch nós estamos
no mundo por demanda
a nossa nossa sala de aula também
precisa oferecer isso ou virar peça de
museu
e esses jovens por conta disso chegam
numa na nossa escola com a carga muito
maior de informação
obviamente que por conta disso tudo a
conexão é uma grande ferramenta que
esses professores nossos podem utilizar
a condição de seus alunos e quando estão
com esses aparatos tecnológicos mas
temos que tomar cuidado porque não é só
a conexão
temos outras estratégias e eu tenho
certeza que aqui por esse palco vão
passar inúmeras experiências muito
legais
como já passaram em outros estádios x
unisinos que eu assisti que vão
demonstrar que a gente tem outras opções
e que isso a gente tem que utilizar com
os nossos alunos
oxalá um dia teremos uma conexão
realmente boa para todos nós temos que
pensar em planos b
aquela característica de qualquer hora
em qualquer lugar
ela começa também a aparecer porque eu
preciso aprender matemática nos 50
minutos da minha aula
eu tenho um mundo cercado de matemática
cercado de ciências
cercado de história porque eu só posso
aprender
naquele exato momento em que cantou na
aula
mas uma coisa muito interessante é que a
partir do momento em que você coloca que
você não o que você coloca que você
permite que o seu aluno efetivamente
trabalhe com o seu próprio de vai se
você consegue desenvolver autonomia
porque ele pode escolher que site
utilizar ele pode escolher inclusive ele
vai querer usar aquele equipamento não é
mais do que um decorador a gente é
efetivamente um aluno que seja autônomo
suficiente para entender quando ele
precisa utilizar ou quando é mais eficaz
uma ferramenta ou outra
obviamente hoje em dia mais professores
e as estatísticas mostram que mais
professores estão utilizando recursos de
informática do que antes mas cuidado se
você fizer uma pesquisa um pouquinho
mais 44 qualitativa em vez de
quantitativo você vai perceber que esses
professores estão utilizando mais
informática mas eles estão usando as
redes sociais também
isso não significa que esses professores
a partir do momento em que sabe utilizar
sabe utilizar como estratégia de de do
seu da educação que ele oferece para os
seus alunos
então ainda existe uma um caminho muito
longo a ser percorrido em termos de
capacitação de professores para esse uso
e olha que coisa interessante daqueles
que já usam tanto alguns deles conseguem
utilizar dentro de sala mas fora de sala
também respondendo dúvidas de seus
alunos por e-mail e etc mas isso é
perigoso porque os nossos contratos com
os professores efetivamente precisam
também ser renegociados repensadas
ese precisa existir alguma coisa nova
também professor se proteger para não
ser obrigado a ficar respondendo
mensagens dos seus alunos às duas da
manhã
e outra coisa que a gente tem preço que
eu tenho percebido muito nas interações
que eu faço com professores é que a
gente também tem um lugar comum aqui
onde a gente fala que professores não
gostam de tecnologia mas na hora em que
a gente coloca a tecnologia na mão deles
mesmo que no começo esse uso seja
rudimentar
eles vão utilizar e eles utilizam e eles
perdem seus medos
então isso é uma coisa muito
interessante o que vem primeiro o ovo ou
a galinha bota os dois juntos eles
resolvem e por último gostaria de tentar
tirar de todos nós um mito imigrantes
nós somos imigrantes digitais eles são
nativos digitais e por isso que eles
sabem nós não sabemos imigrantes
consegue se virar em qualquer qualquer
contexto
se eu for para os estados unidos porque
eu consigo falar inglês é um morro de
fome
bota algum desses palestrantes que estão
aqui que falam inglês no meio da senha
não tenho tanta certeza assim se eles
vão conseguir se virar
então professores efetivamente tem que
trabalhar isso
e pra finalizar a gente tem que ter
muito certo na cabeça que a tecnologia
até auxilia na mudança do paradigma mas
ela não é a solução e ela não vai
transformar uma boa escola numa escola
ela é simplesmente um indutor dos
anseios e crenças da própria escola
daquele lugar onde elas estão
então não achem que todas essas
maravilhas que serão apresentadas aqui
em termos de tecnologia na educação por
si só vão fazer as nossas escolas
melhores
elas vão simplesmente potencializar os
anseios e as crenças do que a gente já
tem
muito obrigado gente